welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and this is you and this is the guy she
tells you not to worry about
episode 81 division ended with a
cliffhanger bigger than the cliff
hanging in mission impossible 2
and it looks like our heroes are tom
cruising for a bruising as we head into
the finale
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down our theories on what's
going on
as well as how the series might end so
far we've got two theories right out of
200 so there might be some spoilers here
especially if you haven't seen the last
episode if you enjoy the video then
please click the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way
you are the scarlet witch now let's get
into the video
okay so the first thing i want to talk
about is project cataracts
and how it could be affecting vision
going forward
i risk painting myself into a cornea
if i use too many puns in this and as i
don't want you rolling your eyes
throughout the video
i promise that's as bad as it's gonna
get you some of a [ __ ]
now though we've thought throughout the
series that something else is going on
with hayward
the episode revealed that he's nothing
more than a paranoid individual
who was deeply affected by the snap as
one of the leftovers in a position of
power
many likely looked to him for guidance
and thus he had to come up with an
extreme way to protect the planet
ultron was initially created to be a
suit of armor around the world
however he pushed back more than black
widow's release date
and eventually tried to wipe out
humanity as bad of a lad as he was
he did do some good and created vision
who ended up protecting us
from his evil father vision was a force
for good that was logical in all of his
decisions
and it's easy to see why he would
believe that he could reactivate him to
protect us from a thanos level enemy
though this one against his last will
and testament the guy is technically
just a fancy alexa
and therefore hayward thought he was
doing something for the greater good
during the scene in his office it's
almost like he was tempting wander to
bring him back to life
and shout outs to michael o'hara on our
last video for pointing out that him
saying
not everyone can bring their soulmate
back online was somewhat of a challenge
to her
she almost did it but she probably
realized she didn't want head from just
a head
so made like the vision and decided to
head off
now if you know vision from the comics
then you'll know that the white version
of him
is completely devoid of personality and
he's basically a husk of a man that just
executes orders i can't see him building
a swing for the kids
and no doubt sword had repurposed him to
take down wonder
at this point hayward still believes
that she's the one behind it all
and if we look at things from his
perspective wonder seems like the
greatest threat to humanity at this
point
therefore i think in the finale after
agatha is defeated
that he will be dispatched into the hex
in order to take wonder and her kids out
we will likely see a vision vs vision
fight similar to the ending of logan
in which the hex one has to take down
the white one
i really don't know who i like more at
this point but i do think that both
visions
will be destroyed in the final battle if
you remember the intro to far from home
then you'll recall that there was an in
memoriam bit for vision
and as that film happens after the show
in this timeline
it seems like he dies if you've been
checking out the cast lists on google
you'll have also seen that james spader
is listed amongst the actors
so it might even turn out that he's
voicing the villain which i think would
be an awesome twist
now white vision could easily take out
wanda's kids
but he's also missing the mine stone
which a lot of his power draws from
and therefore i still think it'll be a
fair fight actually feel that the mine
stone will be left behind by the hex
one's corpse
and that this will help to restabilize
reality for a bit
in endgame it was explicitly stated that
removing the infinity stones from the
timeline
would have disastrous effects and thus
if wonder can create one
then she may have to bring the others
back now what's hilarious about this
white vision reveal
is that paul bettany has been saying for
weeks now that in the show
there's an actor he's wanted to work
with since he was a boy
his full quote reads it's an actor that
i've longed to work with all of my life
we have some amazing scenes together and
the chemistry between us
i think extraordinary it's just
fireworks on set
so i'm really excited for people to see
that stuff
that was actually a recording of his
voice i don't know if you could tell now
the guy is such a troll yeah and i think
in respect
that it's very likely that he was
referring to himself
though i would have loved to have seen
mark hamill or al pacino
i think he got us with that one just
because of how over the top he was
in his praise for the actor now saying
that i do think that
doctor strange is coming and he is of
course someone that protects reality
from massive magical attacks like this
should agatha get too powerful and drain
the abilities from wonder
then she will be viewed as a threat and
he might have to step in and help out
benedict cumberbatch did actually pop up
in one of the zoom calls promoting the
show
so i wouldn't be surprised if he shows
up for the finale before we follow the
characters into doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
i can't see the two kids being killed
and i believe that wonder will go on the
run
and then strange trying to track them
down will be the jumping off point for
the second film
wanda doesn't deserve to have her
brother mum and dad
husband and kids killed so yeah let the
woman have some happiness
please megan now under agatha and in the
latest entry we learned that she dated
back to the time of the salem witch
trials
in 1693. this differs from her origins
in the comics
in which she was a witch who was alive
during the times before
atlantis fell into the sea now why am i
telling you this
i'll tell you yeah it's because in the
comics there's also an ancient being
from
around the same time called chithon who
might be behind everything
i think it's chit on truth on us on
that's it it's it's couth on definitely
and we've officially jumped to the
mephisto train as you might be able to
tell
in order to serve our new dark master
who i think is behind it all
when i tell you some of the things that
he's done in the comics you might agree
that he might be doing it all
and by the end of next week he'll
probably be singing it was
it was true it was kuth or no long
terrible now firstly agatha is being
held on trial in the opening because
she's been dabbling in dark magic
the purple glow of her powers cements
this and i think we can assume that she
learned how to do this from either the
dark hold
or a higher power in the comics it was
actually cathon who crafted the darkhold
and on its indestructible parchment he
wrote his most sinister spells
so that's point one now point two is
that in the comics
he was also the person that gave wonder
her abilities
in the mcu it was assumed that these
came from the mine stone
however in episode 8 we learned that she
used a probability hex as a child
to stop the stark missile from
detonating it's also possible that this
is what saved her and her brother
as that explosion went off pretty close
to their heads and neither of them
seemed to have a scratch on them thus
her having these abilities before ever
coming into contact with hydra
doesn't add someone higher up passing
them down so that she had a purpose
now the final thing is that kuthon has
actually possessed the body of
quicksilver before
and this could be viewed as being
somewhat similar to the evan ps thing
that's going on
in the latest entry we learned that
agatha didn't use the real quicksilver
because his body was on another
continent
and thus she settled for someone who was
similar to him
wanda didn't ask any questions because
of her grief but we have seen him
demonstrate that he has quicksilver's
powers
at least in the hex therefore it could
be possible that cathode was actually
possessing him
and he was the one behind it all along
simply keeping an eye on agatha
and of course wonder that it better be
cut on i'd literally tell you it better
be
i am fully in the mind state now that he
wasn't possessed by agatha
and the snoopers gonna snoop comment at
the end of episode 7
was simply referring to the fact that he
was doing the same
he may be someone totally innocent and
these whole demon theories might go the
way of mephisto in terms of turning out
to be true
it is strange how wanda managed to
recreate vision while she was unable to
do the same thing with her brother
though it was said that he isn't pietro
i actually think that
it could also be revealed that warner
tried to bring her bro back from the
dead
but instead she simply pulled one from
the multiverse rather than him being a
local in town
or or the the dark lord who's
controlling everything
now strangely he and dottie were missing
when wanda drove through the city
so either of them could be the missing
person under witness protection
they might even turn out to be hydra
agents and it could be that whole thing
again
where we get the big reveal that it was
hydra
all along now i know there's just a
couple of theories here but i'm writing
these immediately after posting my video
and sending them off to our editor
christian
to finish up for today when they go live
i'll probably think of a lot more
between now and the weekend so expect to
see another video
soon where we go deeper into things
however i'd of course love to hear your
thoughts below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of march
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase one 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 8 which will be linked on screen
right now
we went over it from top to bottom and
pointed out all the things you missed
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way thank
you for sticking through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you